please be with you welcome to the Dee
Sharma dear host exciting episode today
on the Dee show every week we're here if
you haven't subscribed already right now
do it don't miss out on an exciting
episode every week today we're going to
be talking about a few different things
with my next guest who's worked over 18
years in as an imam in the prison system
and Islam continues not only to be the
fastest growing way of life in the world
according to the Guinness Book of World
Records outside of prisons but also in
the prisons and the institution the
people who work in the prisons they
actually love the Muslim presence in the
prison we're going to find out why my
next guest has also helped over 2000
families at the verge of divorce stay in
the family circuit without losing it
he's helped them stay together
my next guest here on the D show imam
can't don't go anywhere we'll be right
back this is the
this is the this is the assalamu alaikum
peace be with you how are you Sheikh
hamdulillah or they thought I lost until
that thank you for being on the Dean
Sean did I thank you for having me
please excuse me a little bit got a nice
look cut over here was training and I
got knee to the face on accident a
little bit busted up here on the hotel
it was an accident it was an accident
yeah so still managed to make it here I
was excited to be to have you as our
guest here 18 plus years experience here
as an imam in the prison system also
you've helped over 2,000 families stay
together yes I'm little I it's a
blessing from allah subhanaw taala
sometime whenever a lhasa for thought i
want something good for you he blessed
you with an opportunity to do some good
and it's up to us it was it take
advantage of the opportunity that i lost
following that our place is there so you
know we have an opportunity to save the
family so that's what we dedicated our
time in our life - i'm very luck yeah we
like to add in show highlight because
you have it's very sad that the
mainstream media they don't get out
there and highlight a lot of the good
that muslims are contributing to towards
society correct making the world a
better place we like to do that or
highlight some of the good work that
muslims are doing and you're doing some
astonishing great work i mentioned that
it is true the institution why do you
believe that islam in the prison systems
now it is rapidly growing well number
one you know the majority of the people
that are coming to the institution you
know they're coming from a you know sad
circumstances or they ran into bad
situations in their life and now
whenever they you know have all the
activities cut out they have an
opportunity to sit and think and reflect
and ponder about you know what is right
and what is not and then whenever they
have an opportunity to see all of the
different Allen
as far as Christianity and other
religions Islam seems to be the religion
that stands out to them you know it
makes more sense to them
you know so now they can go towards any
any religion all basically in the prison
system you're behind four walls now all
the things that might be distracting you
they're not distracting now you can
really contemplate what's the purpose of
life why we're here now they hit the
books they start reading right exactly
and they come to Islam they come to
Islam you know sometimes it's through
the one that comes in from outside of
the institution like myself when I
started working in the prison system and
then sometime it's other Muslims that
may have gotten itself in trouble and
then they may share some information
with them and then they look into it and
so there's a number of different reasons
why they come but you know Allah soprano
Allah is the one that makes Muslims so
whatever Avenue is their loss Lord Allah
furnish the avenue I just happen to be
one of the avenues that helped to bring
in you know quite a few Muslims into
Islam mashallah is it true now you were
mentioning that the actual the
institution they actually they like the
Muslim presence there
they don't necessarily 100% like Muslims
in general because there's a lot of
presidency against Muslims with all of
the things that go on on television the
media and whatnot but the reality is
ninety nine and nine-tenths percent of
those people who work in the institution
if they are truthful they will say that
the most respected inmates are those who
accept Islam and try to live it inside
of the walls of the the prison why is
that because Muslims if they have a
desire to try to please Allah super Lord
Allah then that obligates them to live a
certain way with good etiquette and
manners and to treat everybody who
deserves being treated right to treat
them right you know and not just use
them or use a broad bristle brush to
paint everybody because maybe they made
a mistake or somebody abused them
use them at some point in their life
whether or not it was a certain race or
whether or not it was somebody from
another religion you know they realized
that they have to use good judgement and
they have to respect everyone who
deserves being respected so Muslim
should equal one with the noblest best
conduct behavior manners he's cleaned up
his act now he's being respectful even
to the to the guards to the inmates and
I mean you would as opposed to is it
that who runs the prison well that I
mean the administration runs the prison
on paper yeah but the reality is if you
have one officer with you know 60 or 100
inmates the reality is if you look at it
you know the the inmates basically
running the prison as far as you know
what's going to happen at that
particular point so you know you you
look at that situation and realize that
the majority of them are basically good
people they just made a lot of mistakes
you know so it's up to us whenever we
come in to try to articulate to them you
know the best way for them to try to
clean up their life so you'd want to be
if anything goes down you want to be
around the Muslims because the Muslims
are going to be very balanced and Justin
helped save the day not exactly having
to today exactly and that happens on a
regular basis whenever there's you know
any particular Dorma area in the prison
you know and in my experience and it's
dangerous you know it's a dangerous
environment of course but whenever you
have a group of Muslims in one area
those Muslims generally don't want a lot
of drama and fitna or crime to go on in
that particular area so whenever
something does happen the Muslims are
generally the ones who squash you know
or stop all of the problems that go in
so human being makes mistakes and now
this individual maybe it was the worst
highway robbery carjacker thief whatever
case he comes in now he learns about
Islam instead of going back out and
doing the same thing he becomes one who
submitted to the will of God
knows the purpose of life night he
reforms his life he becomes an upright
honest human being absolutely what
society wants this is what we want
absolutely absolutely I have some debt
or in there for murder you know I have
some debt not just murder and just maybe
shot or stabbed somebody but I have some
debt did some things that I don't even
want to you know mention on television
you know but those right now are some of
the best and the most trustworthy
individuals that you would have them
spend time around yourself because you
know that they have a love and a fear of
allah subhanaw taala now and god is the
one you know who changes the heart he's
in total control of the heart so it's
not up to us to decide whether or not
this person has changed is what God does
you know and I've seen that and
witnessed it closed hand you know and
many times in the different prison and
not only when you have a sincere love
fear of God in your in your heart in
your mind and your life starts to
revolve around this belief in the
creator and want to pleasing your
Creator that brings Reformation I mean
atheism is not going to change your life
you go in there as an atheist a an
atheist most criminals go in there and
they get a degree now in criminality
they become better criminals they don't
come get out of reform but all due
respect you know even you know Islam the
beauty about Islam is I know some some
atheists and I know some you know some
of those ones who just cannot stand even
to talk about God that have accepted
Islam because they've been around
individuals you know and they've seen
them to change their life so they become
curious and start asking questions about
it and in the different Muslims or
myself at different times you know have
had a general conversation for instance
one individual you know I went by lock
down and I asked him you know did he
need anything and then he cursed me out
so I stood there for a few minutes and
then I said listen I said I don't want
to create any problem for you I said I
just want to respect you as a man I want
you to respect me too you know so the
best thing for you to do is just you
know if I greet you to greet me back if
you greet me I'll greet you back so I
walked down
the the walkway and then I came back and
he apologized right now he's one of the
best Muslims in that institution
amazing amazing we have a lot more to
talk about here in the Dean show with a
mankind
don't go anywhere be right back what are
you going to do with it if somebody's
been trying to deliver something to you
like we've been trying to deliver the
truth that there's only one God you
worship Him alone not his creation
welcome to the bee show one of the most
exciting purpose of life talk shows in
the world since 2006 that the show has
been working on clearing up the many
faults misconceptions about Islam and
Muslims and at the same time delivering
the simple message of the purpose of
life in a fun and exciting way time I
was at a restaurant I was dressed like
this and the woman came to me she said
are you a rabbi so yeah I'm a black
rabbi we want you to develop a better
understanding about the pure Islam and
the real message that it teaches peace
submission surrender on obedience to
Almighty God
Salaam says low blow mankind that's why
we're sharing this message because we
want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind
we'll see you next time God willing on
the Deen show continue to tune in peace
be unto you please subscribe to the D
show follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D sha shake tell us have you
ever been in the middle of a riot in the
prisons where things has just gotten out
of control and you were right in the
middle of it I was in the middle of a
situation where it possibly could have
got real bad we're two different groups
as a matter of fact both of them were
Muslims one had one idea of what should
be done the other had another idea of
what should be done and all of them came
with shanks or homemade or prison made
knives and my intention was to not allow
that to happen and before I knew it I
jumped in the middle and I stopped both
for them you jumped into her jumped in
the middle of them before they got to
each other everybody was standing up you
know I mean kind of looking at each
other looking to to do some things you
know to hurt each other and I stopped in
and I started talking loud telling
everyone to go to the side you go over
there take off those glasses go sit down
you know and I didn't realize that you
know how bad of a situation it was until
after it was over you know few people
got locked up you know and everything
was squashed and on my way
home you know I realized that you know
it wasn't necessarily the smartest thing
but um did a lot it helped because had
there been some bloodshed at that
particular time then they want to cut
out all of the meetings for the Muslims
and the Muslims were the ones that
needed to really be able to move around
the institution in order to bring you
know some type of peace you know and
balance to the whole entire community in
the institution all right so you have
that scenario you have two sides they're
ready to come out each other knives
shanks and the whole getup you're
between it you help calm it down or have
you ever been between now to another
scenario here's one we've got a husband
and wife and things are about to blow up
is that that's a regular basis yes so
talk to us about this in as a matter of
fact in many instances or many ways
that's even worse than the yeah in a
prison system because everybody has a
personal stake you know any other person
you know what I mean and they know each
other and they have more than likely
just allowed anger and whatnot to build
for so long and maybe the rights of the
other person was not being observed by
the other person so it can get very very
uh strong in those particular instances
yeah so you got you must have a lot of
experience I mean two thousand plus
families you've helped I mean this is
over a span of how many years we opened
up in 1999 1999 since then you can say
hum did a lot of thing created heavens
and earth that you were able to save
over 2,000 families from hamdulillah my
way my way of personal counseling and
conferences that we had you know that we
would design the conferences strictly to
strengthen the Muslim family as a matter
of fact the name of the conference's
that we had and we had six conferences
strengthening Muslim family and all of
those were strictly to address issues
that went on
the family you know between husband and
wife and and parents and children you
know and things of that nature so you
know with the help of Allah support
Allah we designed every talk and every
breakout session and seminar that was
going to be able to give each person
that came whether or not they were young
or older had been married for a long
time or a short time or they were
looking to get married you know we would
always give them some kind of
information it was going to benefit them
because the ultimate goal is to bring
them closer to allah subhanaw taala and
there's no way to get somebody closer to
allah subhanho wa taala
than in the marriage bond each other
getting closer to the Almighty yes to
the creator of all that exists yeah
directing them to that and would you say
that I mean this is obviously not your
your traditional behavioral marriage
counseling like the clinical the this is
different is the difference between
clinical counseling and Islamic
counseling clinical counseling basically
deals with the mind you know how you
feel what you think what's your opinion
that's not that but Islamic counseling
is based on the level of Eman the faith
that you have because if you say that
you are Muslim and you have a love for
Allah and you say that you fear Allah
fear displeasing Allah and you have a
hope that Allah will facilitate your
life then whenever someone brings you
information that's based on what I lost
upon what the hell I said and what the
prophets of the Holy wassalam said and
did then you are always try to do the
right thing and change your behavior
regardless how strong your feelings are
toward that mm-hmm
and what have you been in your
experiences what do you see is one of
the number one problems why these
marriages get to the verge of divorce
lack of understanding you know lack of
understanding about the divine
institution of marriage it's one of the
biggest institutions of allah subhanho
wa taala marriage is about a marriage is
worship the same way we line up for
salat and we say this is ebody this is
worship you know the same thing whenever
we get married and we fulfilled our
obligation inside of the marriage as the
husband as the wife you know in a family
member you know we have obligations to
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
more than to our mate so when people
really understand that you know and they
you know accept the fact that this is a
require required action that allah
subhanaw taala wants for us to get
married and to live you know in peace
and and have the love and the
tranquility and the kindness you know
and the tolerance and the patience
inside of the marriage you know then
it's going to bring you closer to allah
subhanaw taala because we are fulfilling
what Allah so Allah wants from us and
the majority of people don't know what
they think that they're getting married
you know just to that one person you
know it's my wife you know your husband
and it's between you two but it's bigger
than that so when you bring a lawsuit on
word Allah into the fray then you find
out that you know you're able to fulfill
your obligation and you're able to have
that peace that allow one for you in the
marriage you know and a lot of times it
starts prior to you getting married you
know how do you you know prepare
yourself to find the right person how do
you find the right mate what do you look
for you know what is the things that you
know is going to help you in the rest of
your life because life is short so you
want to make a good decision so that
whenever you do get married you know hum
that a lot you're going to be able to
fulfill your obligation to allah
subhanaw taala you know and live in
harmony with the person that you use our
last name to make lawful to you and you
have a very interesting story to share
with us how someone can start off the
right way giving us example so you don't
become a chalk line yeah um the chalk
line story when we get back inshallah
God willing we'll be right back with
more here on the Deen show don't go
anywhere
please subscribe to the dgo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show thank you for tuning
in if you haven't subscribed already
subscribe right now and be up with all
of the new shows of the D show have you
ever watched a Deen show shake always
what's the deen so that's why I mean
that's a push a lot so helping to
prevent a war in the
prisons and you were able to do that and
I'm sure not on one occasion I'm sure
how many you you did some wonderful work
there and they loved you there hamdullah
and also now two thousand plus families
and you mentioned something for went to
break doing things the right way doing
things by the blueprint that was sent
from the creator of creation God
Almighty the creator Allah and even
before so and it's just one example that
we can use for many because sometimes
the you know we forget that God loves us
the most Allah loves us he's the one
that we should trust in the most and
whatever he told us to do is for our
benefit right now given give this we
mentioned this chalk store one because
someone there's a way also for a woman
to be protected that she's got her her
bodyguard right you know someone her
family member who's helped weeding out
the rats her wali her walia walia a walk
is that one yeah the wali somebody in
the family or killers is someone that
does the same job but they're not of the
family now the woman's like man look
we're living in a new age I don't need
own body I'm doing my own thing and what
happened give an example you know when
the woman is her own thing what happens
is you know nowadays with the Skype in
the FaceTime and all of those different
things that you know people are able to
bypass the protection that Allah support
Amidala you know has given for them you
know in order to help facilitate you
know finding a new mate and there was
one particular story that we had down in
Georgia where a guy married a sister
they had a couple of children and then
the young man went missing and after he
went missing his sister frantically was
looking for him and she got a knock at
the door after a couple of weeks and it
was the police you know and they said
we're looking for George and she said I
don't know any George and they showed
the picture and there was her husband
she said that's not George that's my
husband so-and-so and said no this is
George you know we've been looking for
him for so many years you know maybe for
four or five years and we just found out
where he was at
and we've been wanting him for the
murder of his first wife and so they
showed a picture of his first wife in a
chalk line just saying in the chalk line
we know when there's a dead body and
there's a chalk line around them showed
you know so this young lady had no wali
she had no one to check you know to do
the due diligence to find out about who
is this person for sure that I'm
marrying you know did she give herself
an opportunity to to find somebody or
that's going to be good to her maybe he
would have done the same thing to her if
she would have made him just that mad
maybe something would have been worse
maybe he would have killed her maybe
killed
you know her children as well so the
process that a Lhasa Paloma thought
allowed the profits of the law it was
salaam to put in two places the wali
system and the majority of the women
nowadays you know they get on all of
these sites you know and they go on the
sites there talking to the brothers
without having a guardian there in the
prophet sallallaahu Dom said if there's
no guardian in a wali and there's no two
witnesses then the marriage is null and
void the marriage is null and void the
marriage is not a void he said it three
times
aisha radiallahu anhum had reported that
Hadees so when the women are looking to
get married and it's not just the women
because sometimes brothers are good
brothers and they end up finding the
sister that they should have checked on
herself you know and we want to be
married so bad that we bypass the system
the good system that allows support
Allah allowed to be put in place by the
prophets of the Lord Salaam so many
times we come in you know sisters say
well I don't have a wildly you know and
I don't need one and I know what I want
and then maybe two weeks later a month
later you know then we have to go in and
try to save the sister from a bad
situation or we just had another
instance that we had to save a brother
from a bad situation because he didn't
do what he should've did and go through
the process being patient you know with
the with the process and how Allah
subhanAllah allowed it to be set up now
you want to go get a car you want to
rent an apartment and the people are
smart enough not to just give their car
to anybody or their house direct or
anything also valued they do was call
the credit check yeah so the person has
a great speech
but at the end you're like man this guy
is great but then the report comes back
and yet that he's horrible he's been
doing this to everybody goes in stays in
the house for a period of time or he
drives the car and then hides the car
for about six seven eight months not
paying for it and it's even worse when
you have somebody and I tell the sisters
whenever they get ready to get married
just call let us do our job you know so
that we can you know investigate you
know do our own personal Islamic
detective work to make sure that you're
not putting yourself in a bad situation
so we have called awhile league we make
sure that you know that she has a wali
if she doesn't she's not supposed to
assign a wily to herself she's supposed
to go to the Imam the Prophet Salla
Louis and I'm said that the Imam is the
wali for the one who doesn't have one
you know so he will either decide to you
man want science so whatever you do he
will do it you know so that you know if
things are not done right in the
beginning it's going to be very
difficult for things to end up wrong you
know just like you know the first right
of a child and I asked some of the
people who come into the counseling said
what is the first right of the child and
very seldom anyone has the answer and
the first right of the child is that the
father finds them a good mother you know
so he's got to do his due diligence so
it's not just trying to find out if the
guy is okay but the guy the brother has
to find out whether or not the sister is
worthy of carrying the seed and then
raising those children and being a good
model and being the nurturer that allah
subhanaw taala created her to be that's
amazing you know one of the
misconceptions out of the many but when
people look into this really they talk
to the Muslim woman they investigate
Islam they talk to the Muslims they see
that all of these false accusations are
actually just a bunch of hogwash and one
of them is that Islam oppresses women
but when you talk to the Muslim women
you see that the majority of people
coming into Islam are women and they get
to see I mean all of these benefits in
Islam and Islam actually is a protection
yes safeguarding her
for many of the pitfalls evils yeah and
it's very difficult you know when
somebody's desires and drives in
motivations is they want to be married
they want to be married like right now
you know and they don't want to wait you
know they make a dua they pray it's
takara you know and they say they wake
up in the morning and see someone and
they said I lost sent them but they
still didn't do the you know the due
diligence to find out if this person is
the type of person that's going to be
beneficial and sometime they may have
children or daughters you know or son
for that matter and marry somebody who's
got a record of pedophilia or something
like that and they didn't do what they
were supposed to do and they didn't let
anybody else do it and next thing you
know they're in a situation where
children are being molested they're
being abused afraid to even go to their
own house the God moves in takes
everything to having it disappear next
thing you know he's on the other side of
the country doing the same thing to
someone else and with Internet people
are allowed to do that so we tell all of
the sisters be patient
fear allah subhanho wa taala regarding
you know what he wants for you and so
that you can have a good outcome and a
good ending that's right yeah tell us
right now people are at the verge of
divorce yes and they need some
assistance some help how can they get a
hold of you well we have a Center for
Islamic counseling and guidance in
Atlanta Georgia and we also have one in
Houston Texas actually two in Houston
Texas and if you go to the to our
website Islamic counseling org there's a
hotline number there and someone will
always answer that phone or they will
call you back you know in a short in a
short time and we'll be able to set up
any type of counseling that you need
either via Skype or you come into the
office and we could help you with
islamic counseling based on marriage at
risk
premarital counseling you have teenagers
that need help and assistance we can do
that kind of work and it's based on what
pleases allah subhanaw taala Quran and
the Sunnah so you actually have a number
yes and call on the internet and it's
two eight one nine one seven
nine zero two six is the hotline number
and someone will always call you back on
that line and get you started into
having the type of counseling or
consultation that you need in order to
help you put more structure in your life
regarding your marriage and your family
operator standing by I think the phone
lines going on already people are
calling ready my last one Allah Allah
you know God all of them to hear the
naseeha you know and take that
information and be better individuals as
it pleases Allah Almighty the creator of
love rewards you for you one for work
thank you for coming today thank you
very much it's a lot for inviting me
thank you another wonderful guest here
on the Dean show sharing his experiences
highlighting some of the wonderful work
that those who adhere to this way of
life are doing out there in the world
trying sincerely to make the world the
community a better place and one part of
the story that we're talking about the
beginning his experiences was were
people who finally now they got away
from the rat race of life they were
locked down in an environment now that
they have to be forced and think they
thought what is the purpose of life why
am I here they started to investigate
all the different religions why don't
you do the same
well you're not forced to be locked up
chained down and then you start to look
and think or you don't even get that
opportunity death comes to you and now
you need to get a chance to really
reflect a thing and now we got two
things staring in front of me on a day
of judgment paradise Hellfire you didn't
prepare for nothing of the next life so
what can you expect out of the next life
wonderful rewards of it no because you
you went and enjoyed all of the
blessings that the crater's given you
didn't denied all the signs one is
coming to you right now so really ponder
and think why am I here what's the
meaning of all of this the God just
create this and just in play and then I
die I'm dust I go to sleep boom wake up
and to another reality wake up before
it's too late
think call us if you have any questions
1 800 662 Islam let's look at the other
alternative what Islam has to say about
the purpose of life and you'll be
fascinated on all of the evidence that
provides how it goes with the common
sense that God Almighty has given you to
differentiate true from falsehood and a
whole new world of goodness will open up
if you're sincere and you want
to know what it is that I'm here for in
this life and we'll see you next time
subscribe if you haven't do it right now
do it right now and share share the Deen
show with everybody friends family and
the world we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you